what is boomer remover and why is it
making people so angry my goodness so
apparently there's this trend on Twitter
where I guess Gen Z or Gen X or
something are not Gen X Gen Z or
Millennials are calling it okay I can't
even open this article now do their
malicious those young uns man all right
I'm gonna try and find something else
they don't care yeah what is here's the
generational divide okay
convincing boomer parents what is this
so I had an article pulled up but
apparently they just get cut me off okay
I'm not gonna go to whatever that it is
yeah see whatever it's it's well you can
explain it so yeah I mean I'm sure most
you guys know it's like everyone's
saying like the corona virus is the
boomer remover like we're gonna you know
like let them all die like whatever
they've had their life it's like
problems with this it's like this this
hashtag that people are just like making
jokes about the fact that corona virus
is only killing old people so whatever
that's why we're gonna go out and keep
partying and going bars and it's like if
I die I die
Yolo it's no big deal we're gonna keep
traveling it's that attitude that's yeah
exactly it's this crazy youth that likes
seeing the world burn you know it's like
it's it's now ingrained in this in this
youth now yeah now you can do it for
likes and cliques and monetization right
yeah exactly it's like they don't even
it's I don't even know if they actually
truly feel that way or if they're just
saying it to get more legs and get more
retweets and whatnot you know did you
pull it up I got the article to work oh
here we go here we go boomer remover no
the big problem I have with it is that
the people dying from the corona virus
are not boomers it's the Silent
Generation the oldest right yeah so
they're people who were born between
like what like twenty seventeen forty
four and in 1946 so that's like a Silent
Generation the sound generation is like
twenty seven to forty six is the
Greatest Generation
no you're wrong okay you look it up look
it up didn't you didn't you tweet that
some sort of graph but I did because I
pulled it up earlier oh right yeah but
it's killing the greatest generation
like 80 plus his 1901 to 1924 okay and
the Silent Generation came after that
then Who am I thinking of from 19 like
44 to 19 I don't know but the Silent
Generation is 25 to 39 okay and so
what's happened now is I guess Gen Z
doesn't know what a Boomer is yep so
there is is to them as far as I'm
concerned is anyone older than them
rights maybe so people straight up no no
not old people anyone older than that
right that's they they're like man we
don't care semantics throw it out the
window
everyone's a fury are you older than me
okay boomer yep it works in any
situation put a stamp on that okay
boomer so is this why it's making people
so angry well I don't know why our
boomer so angry about it they're touchy
I mean they've been blamed for a lot of
stuff there were a lot of stuff so
they're being miss aged what's the word
yeah ageism well let me read this okay
boomer remover a mean nickname for the
novel coronavirus began trending on
twitter a mean one the term has appeared
in more than 65,000 tweets and
references the higher mortality rate
among older people infected with kovat
particularly among people over 60
include er including the Boomer baby age
cohort approximately between the ages of
56 and 74 the nickname is most often
touted by teenagers with adults then
sharing the term on social media as in
this early example I've been informed by
a relative who was in middle who was a
middle school teacher that students are
now referring to coronavirus as the
boomer remover dude everyone always gets
mad at the younger generation they
always do wasn't it like Aristotle yes
like these young kids they're like
reading books and stuff or they're
writing on these weird talat things it's
the end of the world
no matter what happens it's always the
next generation is wrong the next
generation takes over and the next
generation calls them wrong and so you
know man look I have I told you guys the
story about pants and skateboarding I
think you know or I don't know pants and
skintight pants and baggy pants yo so I
don't know this I'm gonna hire it though
so please go on when I first started
skateboarding I kind of just wore
whatever I'm a little kid right and then
the style that's becoming popular was
skin tight jeans skinny jeans
like stretchy skinny jeans and so me and
my friends were to the thrift store and
we bought you know like my friends had
already a bunch of people I knew it
already had skinny jeans and they were
like you should wear these pants they're
better skating it's true actually
stretchy pants are the way but but like
sweet G pants like I was wearing big
baggy pants yeah and then also an I
could see better and I'm like wow this
is cool and plus it was the trend it was
fashion I was like yeah look at me and
my super skin tight pants but the older
guys who are like 20 wore big baggy 90s
jeans and they would make fun of us all
day and they'd be like dude you guys
look like weirdos with these skinny
jeans you know like you look like girls
blah blah and we would be like you know
we'd essentially say okay boomer like
yeah okay dude okay boomer yeah like
you're old whatever you're you're now
outside of our bubble basically like you
don't get you don't get what we know is
in the know that you're a boomer but
these were like these were these were
older dudes didn't matter they weren't
as good as the pros and so we looked at
I'm like they're calling each other
boomers if there's someone in their
group that doesn't agree with them
they're like okay boomer like yeah well
everyone's a boomer that is what in
their their circle essentially here's
what happens when I started getting
older mm-hmm then I'm now like 19 or 20
and things relax a little bit I started
wearing regular like they start regular
stretchy jeans that weren't super skin
tight became yeah but so then all of a
sudden kids started wearing pants that
didn't go down all the way to their
shoes so they were like two inches short
like floods yeah yeah so then and then
people would be like where's the flood
Beavis like what up today and then all
of a sudden the people around me who
wore skinny jeans started making fun of
the kids of the floods and I would I
laughed and I'm like don't you remember
when they made fun of you for your pants
yeah you're making fun of them for their
pants like this is an endless cycle of
people who just don't like the next
generations pants yes and I was like bro
I said to the other kid I was like dude
do your thing man
right on and I started skating you know
like why am I gonna rack like I'm why am
I gonna do the same thing they did to me
that's so dumb right I thought it was
stupid I think it's stupid so this is
what always happens you know I say men
okay boomer when they complain I'll be
like I'm right there with you man you
know like they're there articles they're
kind of funny where like they've written
them saying like boomer is an ageist
slur and how do you guess what Twitter
has banned it oh you serious yeah
Twitter ban Twitter said you can't make
some fun of someone based on their age
group Wow they probably because the way
Twitter looks at it is like if any
specific group feels uncomfortable on
our platform they'll leave and we're
gonna lose money yeah well we need money
right well it's as long as they don't
take up the tic-tock business oh my gosh
yeah sure
tick tock moderators are ordered to
suppress posts from ugly poor obese and
disabled people in order to attract new
users new documents reveal this is that
this is the platform being used by all
the young people right so they want to
keep the users the people who are
actually using it so the people who are
made fun of are the minorities so they
just let's just get rid of those check
this out check this out look the
intercept obtained internal documents
that states certain videos have been
hidden because they show quote rural
poverty seniors with too many wrinkles
beer bellies and crooked smiles boomers
they're hiding seniors on tick tock
they're hiding boomers the report
suggests the Chinese video sharing app
is concerned that posts shared by
unattractive users could decrease the
short-term new retention rate Wow in
addition is singling out unattractive
users the documents also reveal the site
is censoring live streams containing
political speech that would harm
national honor and banning those who
create such content that's China that's
China you're talking about exactly it's
exactly what everyone ever wanted they
want you don't you know the funny thing
about Tech Talk is let me um let me be
very careful Lamanna and how I phrase
this next thing I'm going to say to
everybody so let's just talk about a
different hypothetical social media
company okay where what they do is they
create a bunch of bot accounts and then
they advertise to high school kids who
then start using it they then start
giving those high school kids fake
followers so they think they're getting
popular and then they go and brag about
how many followers they have to their
high school friends who all then
desperately
up for the app trying to get popular as
well and let's just say this
hypothetical app had a different name at
one point and this is the so I'm
actually not talking about Tic Tac by
the way I'm saying like this is a common
tactic that used by a bunch of companies
yeah there was a member being hit up by
somebody and they were like have you
started using this new app which I'm not
gonna name someone gets sued and I was
like no I haven't they're like dude I
have hundreds of thousands of father
it's amazing watch this and they did a
stream and all of the comments guess
what the comments were all the same
they were like keep it up great work
looking good man it was like reminds me
of Rick and Morty when when the AI
people were like oh yeah when they took
over the bodies no no when they were in
the simulation and the guy was like my
man get off my lawn it was like okay I
just kept saying the same thing over and
over again yes guy yes yes my man yeah
you're off my lawn or some like that and
so like the comments were like this is
so great you're funny haha this is
awesome keep it up great work and I'm
like second why are these people saying
this to you yeah who are these people
yeah what is the stream what do you and
how do you have hundreds of thousands of
people following you right now like no
one's using this no one's talking about
it a common tactic used by companies my
understanding and I could be wrong I
have to say that for legal reasons by
the way reddit Twitter they all do the
same thing Facebook didn't because
Facebook was a natural like snowball
rolling down a hill but my understanding
is that reddit they created fake
accounts so that when new users came
they would interact with a bunch of fake
sock puppets to make them feel like they
were actually having conversations so
they'd stay and I heard the same thing I
heard the Twitter did the same thing
which I'm not again yeah I could be
wrong it's rumors but apparently early
on the rumors were that Twitter created
fake accounts convinced people they had
followers so they would use it and think
they were talking to people and then
they did a big marketing push that
Twitter would now appear and they would
say things like look how many users we
have or they would say like accounts or
like active accounts and that's the big
the big trick I suppose interesting yeah
well we did a nice little segue there
from making fun of Millennials I don't
want a Boomer as to social media yeah so
they're not boomers who are in danger of
dying from coronavirus no what would you
call them silence they're all boomers in
their eyes quiet fault everyone on
anyone who used the term boomer like
this new generations that's just saying
okay boomer yeah but there they are true
everyone like our window of what a
boomer is we have this nice bracket
system like from this age to this age
you're a Silent Generation from here to
here you're a boomer yes I got the
Millennials here no no there's no buts
everyone above them okay here's the big
bracket now it's like if you're older
than them two alive you're a boomer yeah
this is our mindset but objectively
speaking coronavirus is killing people
of a certain age that is Jeff Court is
not boomer remover it is the silent
silent killer silent killer I don't know
you know that's pretty bad
people on social media will often try
and find something to think so they can
like try and get on your nerves like
they'll try and call you something like
for me I guess they seem to think that
calling me pim tool like what that it's
gonna affect you yeah like they're like
I don't know I I don't know if it's like
a tribal signifier yes or if they
actually think I'm bothered by it yeah I
really don't care right dude I don't
read my mentions yeah and like I
wouldn't care if you called me anyway
cuz I don't understand what it means
that's cool like I don't know maybe
there's one me to talk about it so there
you go you win I guess I'm talking about
it yeah I don't I think it's a pretty
cool like alter ego named Tim tool I was
actually thinking would be funny to do
like man did you like a special segment
where it's like the pin tool character
yeah it's like a fake to take over
you're wearing like a suit or something
right yes and no beanie on right glasses
whoa like very very very tapping papers
today on the board it's like a totally
new kind of like an Alex Jones oh yeah
but like maybe higher pitch like like
old people like that well it could be
like Crowder doing Schuyler Durden right
right right right
well like I remember I remember the
first time I saw it and I was like oh I
was like what what
I don't know that me we're like what was
I gonna what and then now it's like
whenever they post about me they like
it's people on the left and the right
like the people who just like yeah cuz
you know I think a lot of people take
issue with the fact I don't have part I
don't I'm not strong enough partisan
right beer milk toast or whatever oh
yeah I mean let's see that a lot milk
toast is meant to be a bit of
exaggeration because I mean come on man
you hear me rant about social about milk
toast I don't think yeah but but I don't
take I'm not super far left or far right
I don't know what it means but it sounds
so gross it's milk toast the name come
milk is gross it's from my old comment
like toast it's ruining toast for me
it's an old drippy it's an old comic
about a guy who was really pathetic and
weak okay and his name was milky milk
toast because the writer felt that milk
and toast was a very boring breakfast
and so the guy was supposed to be timid
pathetic and boring okay so you don't
consume them at the same you do maybe at
the same time but like my grandma made
it for me one time wait so it was ya
know stomach and I'm guessing that's why
mister milquetoast got that name because
he reminds me of milk steak I think
you've been worse
cool I think the first time someone
called me milk toast offense at her I
think maybe it was meant to be an insult
but I liked it and started calling
myself yeah like I feel like sure why
not I was like I'm gonna whine not like
that's a good point
milk toast fence-sitter somebody was
like he's too much of a Mook toast
offense center for me to watch and I'm
like that's got something to it I like
it I guess I guess you're not gonna be
watching me but I do get actually I have
I've got a bunch of messages from people
who used to be far left who say that
they started watching my stuff and they
kind of backed away from it and also
people who said they used to be locked
away from your stuff or from no afar lab
but also people people told me they
should be extremely angry conservatives
and now become more you know chilled out
watching my stuff and I'm like though
I'm I'm not saying you should or you
should and you can believe whatever you
want like if your of it if you're a woke
Marxist calm you comment on negatively
my stuff all down here
hey but you're here watching I mean
whatever you know I'm just the guy who
complains about his feelings on the
Internet you can comment and tell him to
call me other names in the world what am
I supposed to do and I'm just a guy
trying to understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth well so so like
to the point of the okay rumor thing to
like we'll kind of keep this still on
point oh yeah what I don't understand is
why anyone cares they've written
articles saying like you should not be
allowed to call us to say okay boomer
and I'm like close your eyes why do you
care so much
okay just just close your eyes look away
from the screen however I turn it off on
the side yeah like you know it's it's
the Tyler the crater thing like how was
cyberbullying real just ignore it
hey why do you they're not in your life
they're not in your they mean nothing to
you yeah so so why do people get like
why does this what is it why did why do
people get mad about this stuff I don't
know like if somebody went on like a
foul-mouthed I rate in 17 languages call
me all the names in the book I'd be like
you went through a lot of work I'm not
even bad I'm actually impressed I don't
know man look you got to choose your
battles and if you get easily angered by
things like okay boomer then I mean
they're you're primarily a boomer listen
if you want to improve yourself if you
want to be better and do better and be
stronger and be you know whatever you
can't sweat the little things mm-hmm and
let people call you names because you
know like the the reality is I think
when I first started getting followers
on Twitter and I started getting massive
hate it was kind of shocking and jarring
yeah and I was like what's happening cuz
I'd like thousands of people and all
sudden people are insulting me and I
very very quickly learned like I guess
some people gonna hate you
yeah nothing to do about it it's gonna
be the way it is yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more show
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all in
the next show
you